ED GLAESER: If you grew up in an American or European city over the past quarter century,
the odds are that your parents didn't work in a factory.
Factories today take up a lot of space, they use a lot of machinery and
robotics, and they are typically located in a nice logistics hub
somewhere far from the center of the city.
But if you had grown up an American city a century ago,
the odds were far better that someone in your family worked in a factory.
My great grandfather worked in a steel mill near Pittsburgh.
In this section we try to understand the link between cities and industry.
One reason to care about the industrial city is to understand the post-industrial
landscape of cities like Detroit, Cleveland, Manchester, and even New York.
Many of these places where build up to enable manufacturing and
to house thousands of factory workers.
Today, those factories have left but the housing remains.
And so many of the cities have decayed slowly but unceasingly.
We hope for a better future for Detroit.
But to get to that future we must start by understanding the past.
A second reason why the tale of urban industrialization is so
important is that it illuminates the connection between cities and creativity.
Western cities will never live through another Industrial Revolution, but
they may well experience some other technological watershed.
They may well create such massive innovation.
Perhaps if we understand the industrial past of cities better,
we will be able to handle the next revolution with less pain.
A final reason to think about the industrial city is that industrialization
is still part of urbanization in many countries like China and Vietnam.
I personally suspect that the Chinese cities will contain factories for
only a few decades, and that pretty soon
China will have to deal with places that look a lot like Detroit during the 1980s.
But even if that prognosis is wrong,
a better understanding of the link between cities and industrialization
can improve policy making in the world's remaining manufacturing cities.
Industry, with it's belching smoke stacks,
was always an odd fit into the urban landscape.
But it was, nonetheless, a critical part of our urban history.